Spain has Europe's second highest court
virus death toll behind Italy and it's
nearly 8,000 fatalities have now
surpassed China with the elderly at
high-risk nursing homes in Spain have
been overwhelmed by the number of
infections there are reports of dire
conditions with dead bodies left in beds
for hours
relatives are worried about their loved
ones but they've been banned from
visiting our correspondent Yann Philip
Schultz has this report from Seville
what is happening behind these windows
concerns many Spaniards almost 2,000
nursing home residents have died after
contracting the corona virus every day
more homes are affected
Rafael Moreno's uncle has Parkinson's
and lives in a nursing home in southern
Spain a while ago he learned that the
first cases of corona virus had been
diagnosed there too since then he tells
me the residents of the nursing home and
their relatives have become increasingly
worried workers complain about terrible
conditions in many homes they say
there's not enough protective clothing
and that hundreds of their colleagues
are infected authorities investigating
reports that some workers went home
after the first cases were identified
leaving residents forgotten in their
beds the dramatic situation in many
nursing homes has shocked people here in
Spain the Spanish society takes pride in
its strong family ties and in taking
well care of elderly people possible
criminal neglect and the
feeling of helplessness among family
members have started to affect the
circulation and a lot of Spaniards fear
that the situation in nursing homes
might get worse in the coming days in
the nursing home where FAL Moreno's
uncle lives the management has set up a
whatsapp group now Rafael and the other
relatives feel a little bit closer to
their loved ones in the United States
where the death toll from copa 19 now
exceeds 3000 over a third of those
victims were from New York State whose
governor has issued an urgent appeal for
medical volunteers Governor Andrew Cuomo
called the number of deaths staggering
so far around 80,000 former medical
professionals have answered Cuomo's call
meanwhile a US Navy hospital ship has
arrived to help relieve pressure on the
city's overwhelmed hospitals a welcome
sight for New York as the battle against
the corona virus ramps up a US Navy
medical ship with a thousand beds docked
in New York Harbor on Monday the mayor
spoke of the city's frayed nerves with
hospitals already stretched to a
breaking point we've all been through a
lot these last few weeks and we needed
this boost we needed this hope that's
being created by our brothers and
sisters in the US Navy and the Marine
Corps Central Park in the middle of
Manhattan is the latest site to be taken
over by a field hospital but New York
has been caught in a war of words
President Donald Trump says that medical
equipment already in place should be
enough for the city but the mayor and
the state governor's say they both need
more help from the federal government to
be ready for what's coming it is a
fundamental blunder to only prepare for
today that's why in some ways we are
where we are
we've been at behind this virus from day
one you have the scientists and the data
projections showing you a curve the
curve goes like this you're over here
prepare for the high point of the curve
and do it now when you do it the night
before medics have become the heroines
and heroes of the day and Monday was
even national doctors day but in New
York they've had no chance to celebrate
they're on the front lines in a city
where the coronavirus death toll is
rising rapidly meanwhile other states
such as Michigan Louisiana and New
Jersey also report a spike in
coronavirus cases and brace to become
the nation's new hot spots and all of
this is happening while the u.s. is
still struggling to get testing ramped
it up and to better coordinate the
efforts to combat the pandemic but
President Donald Trump dismisses any
criticism of the federal government
describing their job they are doing as
tremendous on Monday President Trump
urged the American people to vigorously
follow the federal social distancing
guidelines that were extended through
April he said he was not thinking about
reopening the US economy very soon
instead suggested he might be toughening
up the measures in the coming weeks all
right let's take a look now at some
other coronavirus developments around
the world Italy the country with the
most deaths will extend his lockdown
until at least April 12th Italians have
been under lockdown now for three weeks
already France has reported its worst
daily death toll more than 400 people
France has become now the fourth country
to report more than 3,000 fatalities
Brazil's Health Minister has defied
President shyer bolson arrow and urged
Brazilians to practice social distancing
something bolson arrow was not doing
he's been downplaying the pandemic
and opposes regional lockdown measures
and the World Health Organization is
warning that even though the focus is
now in Europe and the United States the
corona virus pandemic is still quote far
from over in Asia and the Pacific region
Hungarian lawmakers have granted Prime
Minister Viktor Orban sweeping emergency
powers amid this pandemic the bill sets
no end date that allows or bond to rule
by decree indefinitely critics are
calling it a power grab rights watchdog
Amnesty International has said the
legislation poses a threat to human
rights in the country while coronavirus
was taken hold of Europe the Hungarian
Parliament here in Budapest decided to
put democracy itself under a lockdown
the Assembly has voted for the
provisions in the proposals by a
majority of 137 yes votes 253 knows no
abstentions by a large majority
lawmakers approved a bill handing
sweeping powers to Prime Minister Viktor
Orban a highly controversial move for
all these measures you are asking for an
authorization without any time limits
which is unprecedented in Europe on
media a gives a rope a bond named champ
paradox the Hungarian prime minister
says he needs these powers to fight
coronavirus after declaring a state of
emergency earlier in March the new law
gives him the right to rule by decree
for as long as he wants during this
period elections cannot take place and
parliamentary oversight is limited jail
terms up to 5 years can be imposed for
spreading falsehoods about coronavirus
the journalists and human rights
defenders fear this could be used to
muzzle them speaking to DW Hungarian
justice minister unit vaga
defended her government's move low is
nothing more about than to provide for
the government the necessary room for
acting immediately for the sake of
citizens health life and for the
stability of the national economy
Prime Minister Orban has promised to
hand power back to Parliament as soon as
the fight against coronaviruses won but
he made clear this wouldn't be anytime
soon
a one success story in battling
coronaviruses Taiwan just over 300 cases
have been reported with five deaths so
far the island has capitalized on its
experience battling the SARS epidemic in
2003 Taiwan moved early to roll out a
coordinated effort this time to teach
hospitals out to cope with the new
coronavirus Taiwan was also quick to
disinfect public transport and to
quarantine travelers once cases started
appearing containment teams isolated
them and tracked down their social
contacts all that was done without
support from the world health
organization Taiwan is not in the w-h-o
because it's not recognized by the
United Nations and that's because China
use it as a renegade province we're
joined now by mr. chun qiang chuan he's
the Dean of the College of Public Health
at National Taiwan University thanks for
taking the time to speak with us now
back in 2003 Taiwan was was hit hard by
the SARS epidemic what lessons did
Taiwan learn then from that outbreak you
know we learn harsh lessons from the
SARS outbreak doctors nurses died you
know
while taking care of the SARS patients
so the whole society is a high alert in
the past few years just to be ready for
the next attack from emerging diseases
and it took us 17 years to be in this
stage and one thing we learn first is
there's any news from China and you have
to be very cautious and you'd like to
check a few cases that report as a
serious as you can so when we learn
first of all of this
Kobe 19 at the time we don't get the
name of that but our government decided
it's a real thing so we took very early
actions on December 31st is earlier than
any countries and de Rome we insist we
have to be on-site to look at it the
situations and we insist it and Chinese
government does
our expert should go there but they were
not allowed to see what they want so
once they returned with we thought this
is serious because person-to-person is
happening there so we took like all the
possible actions we can that time when
the ratio was not advising any tribal
advice and we decided to ban any
travelers from China that I want to ask
you to hop in here quickly because
Taiwan is not a member of the World
Health Organization because Beijing
objects politically did the w-h-o here
miss an opportunity to maybe better
contain this outbreak by not including
Taiwan in its consultations yeah you
know that's if we look at the past few -
WTO has made several mistakes of
delaying the crane pandemics no no even
another right a device to countries if
they could increase time one in the form
of discussion and some of our successful
majors could be attacked by some other
country who are suffering now so by its
fruit in Taiwan it's not good for
tobacco is not good for the rest of the
world yeah do you think do you think
politics one out here over over global
health yeah until now I still see
there's politics over the public hills
you know the rate you're still Rick put
our data under China and it's not right
and even under some of these
descriptions we are who our name is time
one and there is a 23 counties but they
put our name is Taipei and in violence
you know interpreter you cannot get the
correct data that's you had to be very
serious of looking at all the data
reporting from country they have to
verify and if you are using not the
right data you will make wrong decisions
and it make wrong decision on time why
name robbery on China all right well we
have to leave it there thank you very
much mr. chun qiang chuan Dean of
College of Public Health at the National
Taiwan University thanks for speaking
with us
yeah it's my parade years to be here all
right we have to take a look now at some
of the stories making news around the
world Ford and General Electric will
produce 50,000 emergency vent flavors in
the next 100 days they joined car maker
GM in the race to pre repurpose factory
lines to produce ventilators hospitals
across the u.s. are urgently seeking the
devices as they deal with an onslaught
of coronavirus patients Amazon workers
in the United States are worried about
getting infected they have accused the
company of not providing proper
protections and are threatening to
strike business for the online sellers
been strong in recent weeks as people do
more of their shopping from their
computers the largest Dutch flower
merchant says that his industry could
lose between 2 and 3 billion euros due
to to the current coronavirus crisis and
social distancing measures in the height
of what would be flower season most of
the harvest remains unsold and has yet
and has to be composted a painting by
Dutch master Vincent van Gogh called
spring garden has been stolen from a
museum in the Netherlands thieves broke
into the singer Lauren Museum near
Amsterdam which is closed because of the
coronavirus the painting from 1884 is
valued at get this up to 6 million euros
the 2020 Tokyo Olympics will now
officially start on the 23rd of July
2021 the Paralympics will follow in
August the International Olympic
Committee and Japanese organisers
settled on that date a week after
agreeing to postpone the games due to
the pandemic waving goodbye to this
year's games the name Tokyo 2020 may be
staying the same
the dates most certainly not after a
weekend of speculation confirmation the
Tokyo Olympics will take place almost
exactly one year later than originally
planned I proposed holding the games in
the summer of next year and it was
agreed the decision followed a meeting
of the Tokyo 2020 organising committee
which was then rubber stabbed by the IOC
after a call with all Olympic
federations IOC president Thomas Bach
said humankind currently finds itself in
a dark tunnel these Olympic Games Tokyo
2020 can be a light at the end of this
tunnel
a so-called cherry blossom Olympics in
the spring had been considered to avoid
the summer heat but organisers preferred
to have more time to deal with the
postponement we feel it's better to hold
the games next year at summer time for
the sake of Transportation volunteers
and ticket holders around the world for
athletes to fully prepare we need to
give them as much time as possible there
are many challenges ahead including
ensuring that venues will still be
available to use next year but for the
athletes at least there is now some
clarity in the most unclear of times